it's it's crazy isn't it the the  the sensation of heat so there is  nothing that is heating up on our tongue  you're right bills nothing in our mouth  is actually getting hotter  yeah yeah  again that's just a chemical reaction  you perceive as heat you know uh like  my favorite things with the reaper are  uh indian food  it pairs so well with indian food it's  unbelievable vindaloo yeah yeah  is amazing yeah yeah vindaloo's  incredible oh billy you're really  feeling that one  are you getting hot lips  i don't know it's like my whole  i have a little bit of water maybe  i'm going you're no don't don't drink  water it's just going to make it worse  harmonize with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your boy  [Music]